c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur france 24 à la
une ce soir la france de nouveau pointé
du doigt par l'armée parle par le mali
bamako accusent l'armée française
d'espionnage et de subversion une
accusation après la diffusion par l'état
major français de vidéo tournée par un
drone à proximité de la base de dossiers
récemment restituer à l'armée malienne
nous écouterons dans ce journal le porte
parole du gouvernement malien nous irons
également au rwanda le pays déjà touchés
par l'inflation et la crise économique
lié aux deux années de crise sanitaire
va devoir faire face aux conséquences de
la guerre en ukraine
reportage dans un ensemble et puis que
reste-t-il de l'héritage de poids mais
une prime à 50 ans après sa mort que
faut-il retenir du héros de
l'indépendance ghanéenne nous poserons
la question à notre invité à me that
boukari historien spécialiste du
panafricanisme auteur d'une biographie
sur l'ancien président gagnaire
tout survol de l'espace aérien malien
est subordonnée à l'obtention d'une
autorisation délivrée par l'armée de
l'air déclarations des autorités
maliennes bamako accusent l'armée
française d'espionnage une accusation
qui fait suite à la diffusion par l'état
major français de vidéo tournée par un
drone à proximité de la base de gossip
récemment restituer à l'armée malienne
écouter le colonel abdoulaye maïga porte
parole du gouvernement malien
du gouvernement envers les publics du
mali a constaté depuis le début de
l'année plus de 50 cas délibérée de
violations de l'espace aérien moyens pas
des
étrangers
notamment opéré par les forces
françaises l'un des cas les plus récents
a été la présence illégale d'un drone
des forces françaises le 20 avril 2022
dessus de la base de kossi dont le
contrôle a été transférée effectivement
au format le 19 avril 2022 le drone
était plaisant à partir de 11h45
pour espionner nos vaillantes format
pour être complet sachez que paris ni
paris pardon ni le ministère des
affaires étrangères ni l'état major des
armées n'ont réagi pour le moment et
puis la haute autorité de la
communication du mali a rendu publique
sa décision de suspension définitive de
france 24 et de rfi au mali france mais
diamant de conteste avec force une telle
mesure et utilisera toutes les autres
voies de recours possibles nous
continuera à couvrir l'actualité au mali
qui intéressent tout le continent et le
reste du monde toutes les solutions
techniques seront mises en oeuvre pour
rendre accessibles nos médias aux
maliens et aux maliennes qui souhaitent
continuer à nous recevoir elle fait même
france médias monde rappelle son
attachement à l'indépendance et à la
liberté d'informer
on en vient à l'augmentation du smic au
bénin qu'il a été actée à mardi après
six heures de discussions entre les
partenaires sociaux et le président
patrice talon le salaire minimum
interprofessionnel garanti augmente dans
le privé de 30% passant de 40000 à 50000
francs cfa dans le secteur public il y a
eu également un accord d'augmentation
sur les salaires en raison de la cherté
de la vie écoutez la réaction du leader
syndical de la cosi bénin noël chat
d'arrêt au micro de notre correspondante
à cotonou emmanuel sotchi
où le privé c'est que
l'augmentation du smic qui a été n'est
ce pas accorder accepté à hauteur de 50
de milan passe de 40000 à 50000 et comme
je vous l'aï dit c'est un accouchement
au forceps
ça n'a pas été facile nous pouvoir n'est
ce pas porter un coup de main au
patronat qui a émis des réserves sur
l'augmentation du smig et à 60000 comme
nous on avait souhaité on appeler comme
ça parce que quelque part les liens ont
peu bougé mais ce que ce qu'on ne s'est
pas entendu avec le gouvernement c'est
la hiérarchisation des salaires parce
que quand on augmente le smic on devrait
pouvoir là devraient impacter les autres
saleh on pourrait constater que les
salaires dans les entreprises dans le
secteur privé pourrait ne pas avancer
alors que dans le secteur public on a
convenu qu' on augmente selon les
paliers et ça va vous démarrez mongomin
novembre et il savait un peu deux poids
deux mesures ce délai supplémentaire
demandé par le burkina faso et la guinée
à la cedeao ouagadougou et conakry
demande plus de temps pour présenter une
feuille de route pour la transition une
demande après l'expiration d'un
ultimatum de l'organisation ouest
africaine ce lundi
direction le rwanda refoulé conséquences
de la guerre en ukraine commence à se
faire sentir le prix du blé les prix du
blé pardon flambé sur le marché
international alors que l'économie du
pays est déjà très impacté par deux
années de crise sanitaire notre
correspondant à kigali est allé à la
rencontre de ceux qui sont en première
ligne reportage signé simon wohlfarth
comme tous les matins doux latif wind in
singapore acheter de la farine de blé
pour son restaurant de galettes
2 euros pour deux kilos de farine c'est
25% plus cher qu'avant le début de la
guerre en ukraine
depuis trois semaines il ya eu une
flambée des prix
le prix est passé de 1 euro 70,1 euros
81 1 euros 90 2 euros et aujourd'hui
c'est de 0,20 pour mes clients réguliers
le prix reste toujours à deux comme
clients oui nos meilleurs aux ce petit
commerçant tient les shops deutsch a
pâti la plus réputée de kigali malgré sa
renommée il a perdu en quelques semaines
la moitié de son salaire journalier ici
une crêpe se vend 10 centimes d'euro
pour garder mes clients j'essaie de ne
pas augmenter les prix à l'unité de
cette chapati
mais pourquoi penser j'ai dû réduire ma
marge et leur taille
mais pour certains économistes ronde et
l'inflation risque de continuer de
s'accélérer estimant que le gouvernement
devra rapidement trouver des
alternatives au blé russe qui représente
64 % des importations du rwanda dans le
court terme il faut changer les
habitudes alimentaires les pratiques
investir plus dans la logique sera
certainement initiatives sont envisagées
notamment
à l'exploitation de
céréales produit local va comme les les
maïs qui est excessivement produits
comme le sorgho et aussi le tubercule à
différents types de recul les autorités
disent envisagé plusieurs scénarios
d'après des données officielles
l'inflation généralisée va entraîner un
ralentissement de croissance économique
du pays cette année prévue à 7% soit un
recul de près de 4 points par rapport à
il y à 50 ans jour pour jour c'est
aigner kwame nkrumah père de
l'indépendance ghanéenne il est
également considéré comme le porte
étendard du panafricanisme au même titre
que le burkinabè thomas sankara ou le
congolais patrice lumumba son portrait
signé florent roudaut
une afrique forte et unie c'était son
rêve
docteur en théologie agrégé de
philosophie kwame n'krumah se fait un
nom en 1949 il fonde le parti de la
convention et appelle à la désobéissance
civile les autorités coloniales
britanniques le jette en prison le début
paradoxalement de son ascension
politique car sa formation remporte les
élections de 1951 sa libération prend
alors des airs de triomphe populaire
dans les rues d'accra en moins d'une
semaine
kwame n'krumah troque son uniforme de
bagnards contre un costume de premier
ministre d'un gouvernement autonome
cinq ans plus tard nouvelles élections
générales il assoit son pouvoir remporte
trois quarts des sièges et force londres
a concédé l'indépendance du pays en 1957
finie la côte de l'or place désormais au
ghana images ici de la reine elizabeth à
accra en 1961
mais les relations avec la couronne se
dégradent vite devenu président le
rédempteur comme il est appelé se tourne
alors vers l'est l'union soviétique la
chine aussi londres s'inquiète mais
kwamé n'krumah n'en a cure il est prêt à
accueillir n'importe quel mouvement
subversif pour la grande bretagne il
devient vite un adversaire en puissance
au ghana aussi la colère monte car sur
place toutes les voix dissidentes sont
étouffées il est la cible d'au moins
quatre tentatives d'assassinât
couronnement de son action et sûrement
de sa carrière en octobre 1965 kwame
nkrumah reçoit accra la plupart des
chefs d'état africains appartenant à
l'onu à ce sera la dernière fois qu'il
aura l'occasion d'exposer à ses pairs
son panafricanisme
l'afrique doit s'unir c'est son message
et il propose d'en être le chef la
méfiance s'installe chez ses homologues
farouche anti colonialiste il est
renversé par un coup d'état militaire en
1966 alors qu'il se rend en chine il
trouve alors refuge dans la guinée de
sékou touré
père de l'indépendance du ghana kwame
n'krumah n'y retournera jamais de son
vivant il s'éteint en 1972 en roumanie
loin de son continent
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
d'abidjan avec and that boucard
historien spécialiste du panafricanisme
hauteur de kwamé n'krumah paru aux
éditions cetim en 2016 merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous alors tout d'abord
qu'est ce qu'il faut retenir de
l'indépendantiste du panafricanisme
krouma et que faut-il retenir du
président y at il deux héritages
oui bonsoir je dirais qu'ils effectuent
deux héritages celui du père fondateur
du gala donc ni le gala la dépendance le
premier pays d'afrique subsaharienne à
l'indépendance
aucune avec moment ce national avec
derrière à projet continental donc
panafricaniste qui vit et un construire
qu'il appelait les états unis d'afrique
et donc à utiliser l'indépendance du
ghana pour libérer le reste du continent
africain et s'assurer que les états
africains est dans un ensemble
supranationale qui aurait permis à
chacune des souverainetés à quel d'être
plus forte donc il ya effectivement un
héritage c'est le père fondateur du
ghana donc c'est quelqu'un qui est dédié
à victoire monsieur ping mais le combat
qu'il a donnée débat très largement les
encarts de gala il est acquis des uns
peut vraiment le la figure de référence
du panafricanisme ont quand même
cohérent son projet national et le
projet continental qui fait vraiment la
particularité d'accueillir 11,2 de
khroma alors est-ce que soixante ans
après les indépendances la jeunesse
africaine se réapproprier l'héritage de
ses personnages pensent également à
thomas sankara au burkina faso dont on a
beaucoup parlé en raison de la tenue du
procès de son assassinat ou pourquoi pas
même patrice lumumba
oui il y a un travail de réappropriation
qui se fait aujourd'hui dans les milieux
artistiques dont les milieux militants
dans les milieux intellectuels qui au
suicide un prénom de figure cette époque
cette époque glorieuse des buts
indépendantistes ont tjrs impérialiste
mais qui correspond peut-être aussi un
désir de voir des nouvelles figures
africaines portée des positions fortes
sur la scène internationale donc la
jeunesse il reconnaît donc les
dirigeants qui avaient des projets
ambitieux pour le continent africain et
qui ont requis traquer l'ennemi qui sont
tout à fait pertinente par rapport aux
défis que connaît le continent africain
soit les défis sécuritaires avec les
projets d'une armée continental les
définit monétaire avec la question d'une
banque centrale africaine ont les défis
diplomatiques avec l'idée que l'afrique
doit parler d'une seule voix donc il ya
une actualité de cogner au mas de thomas
sankara de patrice mamba qui est très
intéressant et qui répudierait à
travailler au niveau notamment des
programmes pour saignement et des
programmes universitaires alors pourquoi
y at il justement des personnages qui
sont tombés dans les oubliettes de
l'histoire je pense notamment aux
camerounais ruben
neobe pourquoi est il tombé dans l'oubli
alors certaines figures sont
effectivement tombés dans l'oubli tout
simplement parce que l'histoire est
écrite par les vainqueurs et ruben um
nyobé avec l'union des populations du
cameroun qui est parti d'une butte
indépendantiste qui a malheureusement
été sauvagement réprimés et qui n'a pas
pu porter ses fruits le cas de combattre
c'est un chef d'état quelqu'un qui a mis
de panafricanisme au pouvoir et qui a
été aussi en mesure je dirais d'écrire
sa propre histoire donc il ya
aujourd'hui un travail au niveau des
historiens pour remettre en avant des
figures qui ont lutté pour
l'indépendance de l'afrique mais qui ont
été écartés précisément au moment où on
sait d'indépendance sont parrainés donc
ça pose effectivement un travail sur le
devoir de mémoire et sur l'actualité de
cette figure comme thème de ruben mode
et qui est quand même un des grands
combattants de la libération de
l'afrique que reste-t-il aujourd'hui du
panafricanisme
alors ils en restent des références
qu'on a quitté au maroc arables non pas
il reste des projets qui ont été posées
et qui n'ont pas pu aboutir du fait
précisément d albert quitté de l'époque
un contexte de guerre froide des
difficultés de développement des
divisions intestines à l'intérieur des
mains centrafricaine il rêve surtout je
pense un potentiel de réalisation de
cette unité africaine à travers de
nouvelle génération qui veut réussir là
où leurs dénis rompt quelque part eu des
difficultés à aller au bout de leur
projet il reste en pas une institution
donc dû nous africaine qui certes a
énormément énormément de difficultés à
faire advenir un véritable
panafricanisme mais qui reste néanmoins
une institution et demie temps et dans
laquelle doit se poser réellement la
place du panafricanisme en tant que
projet de libération et d'émancipation
des peuples d'afrique 1 aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup amusé à te boukari je
rappelle que cet historien spécialiste
du panafricanisme et auteur de qu'est
kwamé n'krumah paru aux éditions cetim
en 2016 merci beaucoup pour votre
décryptage c'est la fin du journal de
l'afrique restez avec nous dans quelques
instants la suite de paris
[Musique]